Darby the dog's birthday was just two days away.
On Friday, Darby would be 15 years old.
That is old for a dog.
"What shall we plan for Darby's birthday?"
asked Mia.
"It is just two days away, and we haven't planned anything."
"We'd better think of something fast,"
said Mike.
"Darby will be unhappy if we do nothing on his birthday.
We always do something for Darby's birthday."
"Shall we have a party?
Shall we take him to the park?
Shall we take him to the beach?"
asked Mia.
"Or shall we take him on a hike?
It is a special birthday because Darby will be 15 years old."
"We must plan a special party for Darby,"
said Mike.
"We have always had a party for Darby on his birthday.
And he will be 15 years old. We have to plan a very special party."
"Let's make a list,"
said Mike.
"Who shall we invite to Darby's party?
What shall we have to eat?"
"Where shall we have the party?
What shall we do for fun?
What games shall we play?"
Mike and Mia planned a special party for Darby.
They invited Darby's favorite friends.
They planned Darby's favorite games.
And they shopped for Darby's favorite food.
But they did not know where to have the party.
Mike and Mia went to the park.
"Is this a good place for the party?"
asked Mia.
"No,"
said Mike.
"It is not special."
They went to the beach.
"Is this a good place for the party?"
asked Mia.
"No,"
said Mike.
"It is not special."
They went to the woods.
"Is this a good place for a party?"
asked Mia.
"No,"
said Mike.
"It is not special."
They went to the mall.
"Is this a good place for a party?"
asked Mia.
"Not for a dog,"
said Mike.
Soon it was Friday.
It was the day of Darby's birthday party.
Where did they have the party?
At the zoo, of course.
It was Darby's favorite place.
Darby saw all of his zoo friends.
And they all sang.
"Happy Birthday to Darby."